hey what is up guys i'm kbhd here and
right about at the end of last week we
got a completely random announcement out
of the blue for the red hydrogen one a
1200
holographic android phone and so when it
happened i gave my initial thoughts on
twitter i kind of talked through it a
little bit and then i've been quiet
since then but people have been asking
me about it about what i really think
about it non-stop for the past couple
days so this is all of that so what
happened was red
yes this red the red who makes the
cameras that i shoot these videos on uh
first they made this hype announcement
on the red user forums they do this
every once in a while but they were like
all right new product coming new product
category get your credit cards ready
it's gonna be lit so of course in the
couple days up to that people got really
excited and speculating about what it
might be is it a mirrorless camera are
they making a stills camera are they
getting into audio what could red be
doing next and then of course the day
and the time dropped and red hydrogen
one was unveiled so it's the world's
first holographic media machine
in your pocket it's a standalone
full-featured unlocked multi-band
smartphone operating on android os that
just happens to add a few additional
features that shatter the mold of
conventional thinking and then this
picture this was the only photo released
of the phone and then there's an order
page 1200 bucks for the aluminum one
1600 bucks for titanium hmm so uh that's
that's kind of weird so red the company
that's making these cameras and these
super high-end sensors is stepping into
the world of smartphones where there's
these huge players already samsung's and
apples and these massive supply chains
how is red going to step in this is kind
of like my two worlds colliding right
now i guess if there's any target user
target demographic for someone who's
gonna buy a smartphone
from red
it's probably me
so yeah i bought both but to be honest
there's not a whole lot actually known
about the smartphone like i said there's
only this one image of it and it's kind
of dark and you basically just have the
order page and this one pdf of a lot of
jargon to decode multi-dimensional uh 2d
3d vr ar mr what is a lot what does this
even mean well that's what i'm here to
try to decode for you and also for
myself because i ordered them so
basically this is how i see it going let
me first of all let me brighten that
photo up a little bit for you it's uh
it's an interesting looking phone and up
front they said it's going to have a 5.7
inch professional hydrogen holographic
display so this is the biggest question
mark of them all because we don't really
know what that is exactly but i kind of
got the visual of like a really advanced
3d experience and it will be glasses
free as well and assuming it's nothing
that we've never seen before which i
guess i can't really assume with red but
remember the amazon fire phone back in
2014
yeah kind of something along those lines
but obviously four years later and four
years better basically red is claiming
you'll be able to really look around and
experience real depth with this display
and of course then we'll have some games
and apps to support it as well
not really sure if they're using the
word holographic correctly in this case
but we'll see and you'll also be able to
create and capture and share these dot
h4v files which are again are going to
be brand new but that should be
optimized for this experience they're
really trying to push beyond normal 3d
and then just looking at the phone
itself that brightened image we have
usbc on the bottom a headphone jack nice
and then the camera up top and a pretty
interesting looking back almost looks
like a heat sink like this phone is
definitely going to be thick and then
some grippy sides maybe also with a
little micro sd card slot door because
the phone does have that card slot and
they're also advertising this next level
multi-dimensional audio to go along with
the multi-dimensional video and of
course we can't see any of the speakers
on the back of the phone which leads me
to believe that they'll be up at the
front kind of like boom sound which i'm
hoping it lives up to and if you read
the way they describe this audio on
red's page it seems like it should live
up to that then at the bottom of the
back of the phone you have these pins
and they look a lot like what you see on
the back of the moto z and z2 this
alludes to the modularity aspect so reds
cameras as you already know are already
super modular via pins for the most part
so you have all these attachable modules
you can build a camera up from the base
to be exactly how much or how little you
want it based on your shooting scenario
it's honestly an awesome system and i'm
a big fan of it but it's also a pretty
expensive one because red makes all of
those accessories and they get to
control exactly how much it costs
because who else is going to make red
accessories so this hydrogen one phone
is planning on using those pins on the
back of the phone to become its own
expanding modular system with some
accessories that i assume we haven't
seen at all yet because it'd have to be
the size of a smartphone but according
to all the patents if you read through
the patent application i'll link it
below the like button if you want to
check it out and read it
it looks like they want you to be able
to build this up to be a full-on cine
camera so you can see the diagram kind
of how it looks attached to things looks
like a full blown lens mount on the back
of this one a sensor mount and the
patent also shows roughly what the front
of the phone could look like so home
button in the middle front-facing
speakers at least down at the bottom so
that's good but then from the side the
additional modules with hdmi and more
ports and more pins looks really
interesting and you can see in this one
the phone is all the way up at the front
and then the modules attach via these
pins on the back and they just kind of
make it thicker while adding
functionality and connectivity possibly
a much bigger and better sensor for
video and photos so we haven't actually
seen any of these accessories in photos
yet but we do know number one they'll be
made specifically for this camera by red
and number two they'll also probably be
very expensive so bottom line
it looks like this isn't going to be the
smartphone for the average consumer
obviously you know that from the 1200 or
1600 price but also the fact that most
people aren't building up a smartphone
to be nearly as thick as like a small
mirrorless camera that don't have goals
that are very different from a normal
person plus toss in the completely
insane sounding hydrogen
holographic display i mean it sounds
like a lot but all that makes it a very
unusual aspect so how do i feel about it
uh honestly i'm optimistic i i think red
knows what they're doing obviously
they're incredible with image sensors
and that tech and smartphones is
something that i'm just kind of
generally interested in but honestly
there's so much good red stuff out there
that i'm also a little bit terrified
there's not that many companies that i
would consider myself a serious fan of
like i'm some of you may argue that but
i think tesla's probably one of those
and red i like pretty much everything
red has ever made that i've ever used so
if this phone
isn't amazing in some way like every
other red product i've used i'll be
super disappointed but it's obviously as
we've seen in the past really hard to be
new in a smartphone game right now and
make any sort of dent or impact even a
company like red which is a huge
multi-million dollar company has zero
skin in the game right now and that's a
big deal but i'm hoping this is the
first of many successful projects that
they dive into in this smaller modular
game so good luck red i hope it's not
just a kickstarter and a money grab i
hope it's a good developing product and
project that we'll see in the future but
that's just me let me know what you guys
think would you be interested in getting
this 1200 android holographic smartphone
let me know what you think thanks for
watching i'll talk to you guys in the
next one
peace
[Music]
you